TOPLINE.
KOPITAR, BROWN,  WIDE.
THE BEST SHOT ON GOAL BY AND
SAVE THERE BY BINNINGTON. ONE RE
AS WE TALKED ABOUT IN OUR KEYS
TO THE GAME.
THEY'RE IS THE ENTRY IN THE ZONE
.
THE DUMP AND THERE BY HIM.
>> WE SAW THE COACH NOW IN THE
HONDA DEALERS.
HEIGHTS OF THE GLOVE SIDE OF RE
KYROU ANY CAN'T GET IT BACK.
>> I'VE SEEN A LOT MORE E NOT H
IS PRETTY UNDERRATED WHEN
HANDLING READS THE PLAY.
PERRONSTOP POSITION.
HE SLIDES, PLAYS IT, AND THEN B.
THE PRESSURE BY THE BLUES.
IMPOR
LET ALONE GAMES.
NOW PERRON.
WE KNOW HE'S A SHOOTER.
>> AS THEY SAY IN THE UK.
NOW IT ISJECTED.
IT WITH THE PAST A BIT.
AND NOW WALKER
THOMAS AGAIN
SOMEBODY WIDE OPEN.
JUST A TERRIFIC DISTRIBUTOR.
WITH THAT ASSIST ON THE GOAL BY
NEAL. THEM HERE THERE ON THE
SEEM TO BE SLOWING DOWN GOALIE
THE EYE AND THE SKY TONIGHT.
ALWAYS LEAVE THAT TO THE FINALE
HE DRAWS ONE BACK FOR EDLER, TH
SHOTS ON GOAL. TARASENKO IN HER
WHERE HE BUY BY SOMETIME THERE.
YOU CAN SEE THE KINGS
SLOWED SLOW DOWN PERIODS THAT
WAS PASSED.